du coup on va passer au débat de ce club
consacré au réfugiés ukrainien et
d'abord Alex les chiffres avec vous sur
ces réfugiés Ukrainiens en France
septembre on comptait 107.000 réfugiés
Ukrainiens sur le territoire français
selon les chiffres de l'offi dont 18500
en France scolarisés dans nos écoles
depuis le début du conflit fin février
ce qu'il faut noter aussi c'est que
10000 réfugiés ukrainiens ont quitté la
France pour revenir dans leur pays ils
ont fui la guerre fin février mais il
souhaitait revenir rapidement en Ukraine
et sur notre territoire si on fait des
comparaisons entre les régions et bien
on peut dire que l'Île-de-France et la
région PACA sont les deux régions qui
accueillent le plus de réfugiés
Ukrainiens mais après il y a une
répartition assez équitable entre les
différents territoires à l'échelle
européenne c'est différent à la France
n'est pas du tout le pays de l'Union
européenne qui accueille le plus de
réfugiés Ukrainiens si on regarde la
répartition en Europe au mois d'août
dernier et bien la Pologne voisine de
l'Ukraine arrive en tête l'Allemagne en
deuxième position aux alentours d'un
million de réfugiés Ukrainiens
accueillis devant la République tchèque
la France arrive derrière l'Italie
l'Italie et le Royaume-Uni aux alentours
de cette barre des cent mille réfugiés
pourtant des pays de l'Union européenne
accorde la même protection à tous les
réfugiés oui en France comme dans le
reste des pays de l'Union européenne et
bien les réfugiés Ukrainiens bénéficient
de ce qu'on appelle le statut de
protection temporaire de l'Union
européenne il est valable un an il peut
être prolongé par la suite et ce statut
il donne droit de séjour accès au marché
du travail aux aides médicales et
sociales droit au logement et les
mineurs non accompagnés bénéficient
d'une tutelle légale et ont accès à
l'éducation noter qu'en France et bien
la location de demandeurs d'asile est
aussi à verser assez réfugiés Ukrainiens
c'est environ 1000 euros quand on a un
enfant à charge même si juridiquement
ces réfugiés Ukrainiens n'ont pas le
statut de demandeur d'asile merci Alex
pour ces chiffres et pour ce point
Didier lesqui est-ce que le flux de
réfugiés est constant depuis 8 mois
alors non il est pas constant il est en
forte diminution depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines si ce n'est même
plusieurs mois disons que depuis juillet
on a une baisse très forte avec des
retours et parfois même des
allers-retours la volonté des
ukrainiennes puisqu'il est en réalité il
faut d'abord parler du crânienne avec
des enfants pour beaucoup c'est de
rester dans les pays les plus proches de
l'Ukraine avoir des contacts avec les
hommes qui qui se battent courageusement
en
Ukraine et donc c'est ça la situation
c'est pour ça que les pays comme la
Pologne ont un taux de présence qui est
beaucoup plus fort c'est pas qu'on
refuse d'accueillir c'est que les
personnes préfèrent rester dans les pays
limitrophes du reste on a essayé de
d'inciter des personnes qui étaient en
Moldavie à venir en France et ça n'a pas
marché parce que les gens ne souhaitent
pas s'éloigner en particulier quand il y
a pas au préalable comme c'était le cas
au Portugal en Espagne en Italie des
communauté ukrainienne déjà importante
la France n'était pas un pays
d'accueil massif des Ukrainiens avant le
24 février de cette année
est-ce que c'est le même projet de
réfugiés qu'on voit depuis 8 mois où
est-ce que le profil a changé
d'abord c'était des femmes et des
enfants il y avait aussi une forte très
généralisation c'est à dire que les gens
venaient des territoires les plus les
plus touchés des directement à menacées
par par la guerre ensuite ça c'est
réparti un petit peu sur sur les
territoires mais on voit effectivement
un des plutôt des femmes et des enfants
sachant que les hommes sont sont front
et parfois il y a effectivement des
retours pour voir la la famille mais
donc c'est plutôt une une immigration
familiale et et donc c'est surtout pour
mettre les les femmes les enfants à
l'abri que les que les que les gens
étaient partis et on voyait d'ailleurs
quand les les
trains qui partaient les hommes déposés
leur leur famille et réparti donc c'est
c'est un profil très particulier et plus
faible Didier lesqui a un flux plus
faible comment ça s'explique parce qu'au
début il y avait évidemment l'urgence et
la surprise de la guerre et que
aujourd'hui avec le temps long les quit
on a accueilli 30 réfugiés
15 familles qui ont été logées dans un
dans un bâtiment du parc social de
Coulaines qui étaient voué la
destruction dans le cadre d'une
opération de rénovation
urbaine et donc voilà les réfugiés
Ukrainiens n'ont pas pris la place de
d'habitants de Coulaines ce qui n'a pas
créé non plus de perturbations parce
qu'on voit bien que parfois il y a une
concurrence aussi un ressenti
défavorable et l'accueil des des
réfugiés Ukrainiens s'est passé dans de
très bonnes conditions voilà nous avons
accueilli les enfants dans dans les
écoles dans les centres de loisirs voilà
donc on a on a une trentaine pour une
ville de 8000 habitants on a une
trentaine de réfugiés originaires
d'Ukraine dans le parc social dans le
cadre d'une d'une d'un accompagnement
par
une association par la Croix-Rouge et
sinon nous avons une demi-douzaine de
personnes qui sont venues habiter chez
des qui sont venus chez les habitants
Didier leski comment ça se passe à
l'heure arrivée de ces réfugiés
craignants comment ils sont accueillis
comment ils sont intégrés quels sont les
aides d'abord je pense que le mot
intégration n'est pas le bon mot voilà
on peut pas
calquer la situation des des Ukrainiens
qui arrivent des ukrainiennes des
protégés temporaires à avec celles de de
demandeurs d'asile qui obtiennent le
statut de réfugiés et qui sont là pour
longtemps la particularité et c'est sans
doute pour ça aussi qu'il y a eu un élan
de solidarité importante c'est que tout
le monde espérait et on espère encore
que le départ soit le plus court
possible et c'est du reste l'état
d'esprit des personnes qui sont là une
partie a été accueillie chez des
particuliers une autre dans des
opérations comme celle qui vient d'être
décrite avec des associations qui sont
subventionnées par l'État pour suivre
ces personnes et des collectivités
publiques qui ont mis à disposition des
locaux on sait quel est le pourcentage
c'est les particuliers ont pris une
grande part dans l'accueil de ces de ces
réfugiés alors un peu moins de 50% aux
alentours de 40% chez des particuliers
et puis le reste c'est vraiment
les publics si vous voulez on va voir
l'illustration de ce que vous dites
justement et de cette volonté évidemment
de ces réfugiés Ukrainiens de revenir le
plus tôt possible chez eux puisque en
avril dernier Jérôme Rabia avait suivi
l'accueil de réfugiés une crénantes dans
une petite commune de l'Isère mince il y
retourner il y a quelques jours pour
voir où en est la situation regarde son
reportage
pierre suzarini est un maire engagé et
lui en 2020 à mince dans l'Isère il
s'était tout de suite mobilisé en faveur
des réfugiés Ukrainiens lorsque la
guerre a éclaté il y a 8 mois nous
l'avions suivi en avril dernier chez lui
il accueillait une famille de réfugiés
Ukrainiens c'est assez grande solidarité
à ce moment-là je sais pas quand il
pourrait y avoir il avait aussi organisé
un convoi pour rapatrier une trentaine
d'ukrainien en Isère et mobilisait tous
les leviers disponibles comme la
transformation de cet ancien local du
Trésor public en logement pour les
réfugiés 6 mois après notre venue nous
avons souhaité voir où en était la
mobilisation dans cette commune rurale
2400 habitants la dernière fois on était
en train de l'aménager et de meublé en
instance d'accueillir une famille donc
cette famille est là une famille avec
deux parents deux enfants les enfants
sont scolarisés il y a une fille qui est
au collège et un fils qui est à l'école
primaire et du coup ils ont un bail de
mise à disposition jusqu'à la fin de
l'année scolaire pour avoir un petit peu
une petite lisibilité sur le moyen terme
désormais il n'y a plus de nouvelles
arrivées sur la commune et une fois
passé l'urgence de l'hébergement et de
la scolarité des enfants il a fallu
préparer la suite et maintenant on est
plus dans une phase dans une phase qui
se d'installation sur le long terme et
il a fallu penser notamment alors
trouver un petit peu de travail parce
que il leur fallait effectivement des
revenus et là encore la collectivité
s'est déployée autant que possible
l'école a été un employeur important de
quelques personnes ukrainiennes il y a
quelques mois déjà pierre susarini
regretté que les communes rurales ne
soient pas davantage associé à l'accueil
massif des réfugiés Ukrainiens en France
et si amince la solidarité locale a
fonctionné à plein le maire espère tirer
des leçons de cette expérience et les
structures les structures d'accueil de
vous réfugier sont quand même
centralisés sur l'agglomération avec des
conditions d'hébergement qui sont un peu
tendues et autres et les ressources
extérieures ne sont pas utilisées donc
là pour moi il pourrait y avoir une
vraie réflexion et un vrai partenariat
mais Pierre suzarinier est aussi
conscient que les territoires ruraux
sont parfois seulement des lieux de
passage la famille andréf qui
l'hébergeait chez lui à déménager Olga
qui avait fait son entrée au collège à
mince a dû rejoindre Grenoble pour son
passage au lycée c'est accompagné de son
père qu'elle nous montre son nouvel
établissement
là c'est la partie déjà terminée et là
c'est la partie en construction donc
voilà ma nouvelle école
la famille était bergée dans un logement
de fonction inoccupé encore un nouveau
départ dans une nouvelle ville pour Olga
et sa famille un séjour a duré
indéterminée qui laisse leur vie en
suspense
oui nous essayons de construire une
nouvelle vie mais c'est difficile quand
on sait ce qui se passe en Ukraine et
donc c'est vraiment dur
en attendant Olga et sa famille
poursuivent leur intégration tout en
gardant leur cœur au pays comme un
symbole Olga suit l'école en simultané
en France et en Ukraine à cause de la
guerre nous avons des cours en ligne à
Kiev donc j'apprends ici et en plus à
distance donc parfois c'est un peu
compliqué de jongler entre les leçons
que j'ai ici et les leçons que j'ai en
ukrainien avec mon lycée à Kiev
comme des milliers de réfugiés
Ukrainiens la famille André espère
retourner au plus vite au pays en
attendant il maintiennent les liens avec
tout ce qui les ont accompagnés depuis
leur arrivée et retourne régulièrement à
mince chez Pierre suzérinier sa femme où
ils sont toujours accueillis à bras
ouverts
avec cette famille qui s'est installée
physiquement évidemment en France mais
on comprend leur cœur est toujours en
Ukraine ça s'est passé comment
l'installation de ces familles
françaises d'autant que ça dure dans le
temps ce qui n'était peut-être pas prévu
au départ est-ce que ça a été facile
pour elle de s'installer de trouver un
travail de trouver une école pour leurs
enfants je pense qu'il y a énormément de
cas de figure ce qui est contre c'est
qu'il y avait une volonté de de les
accueillir c'était là on venait aussi
bien des particuliers des Français qui
sont mobilisés qui sont manifestés et
des collectivités bien sûr une commune
de sainte-menou n'a pas les mêmes moyens
qu'une commune de Paris par exemple pour
la ville de Paris par exemple mais ce
qui compte c'est qu'il y a eu cette
volonté commune et surtout ce sentiment
d'être concerné par par l'arrivée de ces
réfugiés et par cette guerre qui a été
déclenchée à l'Ukraine ça s'est bien
passé pour pour ces réfugiés alors vous
vous ne voulez pas parler d'intégration
vous avez raison en tout cas cette
installation en France puisqu'ils sont
là pour plusieurs mois ça s'est bien
passé d'abord il y a eu un
vraiment très important de mobilisation
puisqu'on a eu jusqu'à 2000 arriver par
jour donc il a fallu organiser ça avec
des points d'entrée très précis je pense
à côte d'azur à partir de Nice et bien
évidemment à partir de Paris avec les
arrivées par train donc il y a une très
forte mobilisation des services de
l'État et qui a permis cet accueil
puisqu'il fallait à chaque fois
enregistrer les personnes pour justement
leur permettre de toucher la location
qui était prévue pour les protéger
temporaires et c'est pour ça par exemple
que l'installation immédiate en zone
rurale était plus compliquée puisque il
faut quand même qu'on aille voir les
personnes et les agents de l'Office
français de l'immigration on fait des
des
convois si j'ose dire dans différents
départements pour aller au plus près des
personnes leur remettre la carte
d'allocataires en ce qui concerne les
enfants
la scolarisation elle est obligatoire en
France quel que soit la situation
administrative des parents
c'est notre législation depuis la fin du
19e siècle et donc les enfants ont été
progressivement scolarisés mais avec
cette particularité qu'on voit bien
partout c'est qu'ils suivent un double
cursus ils suivent le cursus français et
puis en même temps ils sont en lien
permanent avec les enseignants
Ukrainiens qui peuvent même eux-mêmes
être dans d'autres pays que l'Ukraine
c'est c'est une organisation assez
sophistiquée et c'est pour ça qu'on
demande aux établissements d'aménager le
temps scolaire de ses enfants pour leur
permettre justement de suivre les deux
cursus parce que la volonté des
autorités ukrainiennes c'est que ils
gardent un lien et c'est pour ça que
quand on parle d'intégration il faut
faire attention parce que la volonté
c'est de garder le lien avec l'idée
qu'il y a un retour et du reste même et
qu'il y aura une reconstruction et on
l'a vu le double cursus suivi par cette
jeune fille à la fois en français et en
Ukraine ça a été compliqué ça a organisé
il y a des établissements aussi
compliqué parce que
si vous voulez l'éducation nationale
peut avoir ses règles et l'idée par
exemple qu'un élève n'assiste qu'à la
moitié des des genres de cours parce
qu'il a par ailleurs des heures
craignant ça peut parfois heurter mais
enfin progressivement on y arrive et
puis il y a beaucoup de bénévolances
d'attention et c'est ça qui est frappant
mais cette attention et cette
mobilisation elle est justement liée et
il faut pas être dupe au fait que tout
le monde espérait et espère toujours que
ça soit le plus court possible et
Christophe Rouillon je vous pose la
question à un double titre à la fois en
tant que mère de Coulaines mais aussi en
tant que vice-président de l'Association
des maires de France puisqu'on a vu ce
maire a accueillir chez lui les réfugiés
Ukrainiens ce mars maire de mince dans
l'Isère il les a accueillis et dans le
même temps il dit qu'il regrette que les
communes rurales n'aient pas été plus
associée à l'accueil de ces réfugiés
vous partagez ça
oui c'est pas simplement ce sont pas
simplement les communes rurales qui
n'ont pas été suffisamment associées les
communes urbaines sont également de la
même situation je suis maire d'une ville
de banlieue les échanges avec l'État ont
été fort au début de la crise nous avons
d'ailleurs été reçu au ministère des
Affaires étrangers par Jean-Yves Le
Drian et puis panel de représentants de
l'État et depuis je veux dire que c'est
un peu silence radio et on a du mal à
voir quelle est l'accompagnement
possible et ce que je constate c'est
qu'il y a eu un élan massif de
générosité dans le monde rural et
qu'aujourd'hui les familles alors que la
crise ukrainienne dure dans le temps on
voit les familles s'orienter plutôt vers
les villes pour trouver des structures
d'accueil peut-être plus plus importante
et souvent elles s'oriente vers les
villes de banlieue qui ont déjà le plus
de difficultés financières qui doivent
supporter les frais alors qu'il reste
encore marginal il faut pas non plus
exagérer la situation mais si la
situation devait durer je pense que les
communes de banlieue qui sont déjà très
impactées par la crise énergétique en
particulier risque de devoir supporter
des charges très difficiles donc voilà
on a besoin je pense d'un renforcement
des liens avec l'État et puis peut-être
aussi de préparer la prochaine étape
parce que la question aujourd'hui ce
sera la question comment éviter un affût
supplémentaire de de réfugiés s'il n'y a
pas de reconstruction et de mise en
remise en route de l'État parce que
aujourd'hui il y a des régions d'Ukraine
qui sont totalement inhabitables et
c'est là qu'on va devoir on en parlera
peut-être rapidement mais une action
commune au niveau national et européen
pour aider à la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine reconstruire les
infrastructures d'eau d'électricité pour
éviter cette nouvelle vague une nouvelle
vague d'immigration c'est ça c'est
l'action en Ukraine on va en parler mais
vous même est-ce que Vous demandez une
aide supplémentaire de l'État
il y avait un fond qui avait été décidé
je crois deux 300 millions d'euros pour
la somme on n'a pas vu la couleur par
exemple pour les les aides à la cantine
c'est la c'est la commune qui s'en
charge pour les centres de loisirs cet
été c'était également la commune qui
s'en est chargée l'aide alimentaire
également voilà donc heureusement
aujourd'hui les familles d'ukrainen ont
c'était de l'État par l'aide au réfugiés
dans le cadre de la protection
temporaire et d'ailleurs il nous demande
pas beaucoup je dirige assez chichement
ils ne sont pas dans la demande et
beaucoup de familles travaillent donc
aujourd'hui on n'a pas on n'est pas
vraiment sollicité mais on a quand même
des dépenses qu'il faut couvrir et qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas couvertes par
une date de l'État et de quoi vivent-ils
les réfugiés Ukrainiens aujourd'hui
Didier leski et combien coûte à la
France l'accueil de ces réfugiés
ukrainiens
alors combien coûte à la France c'est ça
je
la somme globale je ne peux pas la voir
comme ça vous nous avez parlé d'une
allocation tout à l'heure ça vous avez
un allocation actuellement on verse aux
alentours de 27 ou entre 27 et 30
millions par mois
aux familles ukrainiennes à travers la
location qui est l'équivalent de la
location pour pour demandeurs d'asile en
ce qui concerne la reconstruction vous
avez vu que le Président de la
République annonce une réunion le 13
décembre avec les partenaires européens
justement pour réfléchir à la
reconstruction de de l'Ukraine et pour
mobiliser les personnes après il y a des
aides
à travers le financement des
associations les associations sont
subventionnées pour suivre les personnes
et on a aussi eu la distribution de
tickets alimentaires par le biais de de
la Croix-Rouge donc il y a des choses
diverses qui se qui se font voilà
combien ça coûte à l'ensemble je crois
que en réalité personne ne m'estimait
que il fallait avoir une gestion
comptable de la chose donc les choses
qu'on continue et après localement c'est
autour des préfets que doit se faire les
concertations puisque c'est le préfet
qui est le représentant de l'État dans
les départements
Christophe Rouillon voulait vous
l'intervenir là dessus
oui je pense qu'il faut pas avoir une
vision comptable parce qu'il faut quand
même savoir que les Ukrainiens se
battent pour nous et on met en sécurité
les familles pour permettre soldats de
combattre peut-être l'esprit plus libre
donc voilà je pense qu'il faut pas avoir
cette vision comptable je dirais aussi
qu'il est nécessaire de préparer la
conférence des donateurs du mois de
décembre sur la reconstruction et aussi
de pouvoir mobiliser les fonds européens
puisque 9 milliards d'euros avaient été
annoncés au niveau européen et c'est là
aussi où l'aide peut-être mobilisé en
particulier au Comité européen des
régions nous allons mettre une
plateforme pour la reconstruction
d'Ukraine et l'aide pour les
collectivités territoriales et c'est
aussi à ce niveau repère mon sens qu'il
faut mobiliser ses fonds et peut-être
aussi réfléchir à un endettement commun
Union européenne pour faire face à la
reconstruction d'Ukraine qui est estimée
à 800 milliards d'euros je crois sur
cette question de la reconstruction où
on en est maintenant déjà avant de
parler de reconstruction et un ami très
Chine parce que je ne sais pas si c'est
vraiment encore le temps de parler de
reconstruction il y a de nouvelles
frappes russes il y a des coupures d'eau
d'électricité en
ukra est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il y
aura un nouvel afflux de réfugiés dans
les jours à venir
la première condition c'est quand même
l'arrêt de la guerre donc et la
reconstruction on évalue maintenant les
les besoins on voit que que ces besoins
vont croissants et on constate en même
temps la volonté des Ukrainiens de
garder la normalité c'est à dire que dès
qu'une maison est bombardée dès qu'une
maison était détruite ou donc je vois
une chaussée qui a été détruite on voit
que pratiquement le lendemain les
travaux commencent et donc ce besoin de
normalité d'avoir des des rues propres
d'avoir des des maisons des structures
qui fonctionnent c'est ce qui frappe
aujourd'hui en Ukraine de voir à quel
point les Ukrainiens essaient de tel les
fourmis de reconstruire et de et de de
colmater immédiatement tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est tout ce
qui a été détruit c'est peut-être une
façon de de retrouver cette normalité
qui permet aussi de de tenir et de se
dire on va refaire mais aujourd'hui il
faut que que l'Ukraine puisse gagner
cette guerre parce que n'oublions pas
que le crâne n'a pas besoin de paix à
tout prix et là aussi besoin de justice
et on est évidemment frappé par la
combativité des Ukrainiens toujours huit
mois après est-ce que vous sentez ce
même état d'esprit dans l'opinion
publique française est-ce que pour vous
l'opinion publique française soutient
toujours autant les ukrainiens et les
réfugiés Ukrainiens selon les sondages
le maintien n'est pas n'est pas effondré
et c'est peut-être un petit peu effrité
mais de manière marginale c'est normal
la guerre est là depuis plusieurs mois
donc on entre dans une espèce de de
routine d'autres choses vient s'ajouter
à des préoccupations des des Français
notamment la situation enfin la crise
économique les les prix qui augmentent
etc d'où l'Ukraine n'est pas la guerre à
l'Ukraine n'est pas la seule cause donc
il y a d'autres questions qui entre qui
entre en jeu mais lorsqu'on pose la
question sur le soutien sur la nécessité
de maintenir les sanctions je crois
qu'on ne reste toujours à des larges
majorités en faveur de l'Ukraine
oui je crois que enfin en tout cas moi
je n'ai je ne sens pas
quelque chose qui serait profondément en
recul en termes de solidarité et on
grandir même que l'Europe a fait une
démonstration collective de soutien par
rapport à un pays qui qui a nos
frontières et comme du reste ça avait
été un peu le cas au moment des guerres
dans l'Est que dugoslavie où on avait vu
l'arrivée de de famille importante je
crois que il y a un sentiment européen
dans l'adversité qui s'est exprimée et
qu'on retrouve ici en France et et du
reste vous avez pu noter que il y a peu
de de responsables politiques qui
aujourd'hui
ose dire qu'il ne faut pas soutenir
l'Ukraine et vous vous préparez à
accueillir un nouveau flux de réfugiés à
la fois avec ce qui se passe en Russie
on n'en sait pas
on ne sait pas c'est-à-dire que ce qui
est frappant c'est la volonté des
Ukrainiens sur place de maintenir leur
pays c'est de ce point de vue là on a
affaire à un pays qui existe vraiment et
qui tu restes dans le sentiment national
c'est renforcé à travers
l'agression c'est ça qui est et donc on
ne sait pas trop et puis faut pas
oublier non plus que ce cet élément
important et où la France n'est pas en
première ligne c'est que ce sont d'abord
des femmes qui sont parties avec des
enfants et que leur souhait est quand
même de rester au plus près des hommes
pour avoir des liens permanents avec eux
or comme la guerre ne n'est plus la même
je veux dire on a bien évidemment les
bombardements mais le front Est et
maintenant beaucoup plus loin des villes
et donc c'est plus facile de faire des
allers-retours et c'est plus facile de
les faire à partir de la Pologne que de
les faire à partir de la France et c'est
pour ça que la France aujourd'hui n'est
pas mais pas en première ligne en ce qui
concerne laquelle mais par exemple
l'Espagne qui avait beaucoup accueilli
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui sont
partis d'Espagne qui sont rentrés en
Ukraine et on voit pas actuellement de
de flux vers l'Espagne et donc je pense
que on ne sait pas et on verra quel est
l'impact de l'hiver mais c'est des zones
où l'hiver peut être très dures donc un
dernier mot quand on voit ce chiffre du
faible nombre de réfugiés Ukrainiens
accueillis en France pour qu'on soit
bien clair c'est pas une question de
politique de la France c'est une
question une volonté les réfugiés
Ukrainiens
c'est le cas souvent et c'est peu
compris ou mal compris on avait eu ce
même type de débat avec les Syriens les
Syriens ne souhaitaient pas venir en
France et c'est pour ça que tu en as peu
qui sont arrivés c'est pas parce qu'on
voulait pas les accueillir mais c'est la
même chose pour l'Ukraine mais si demain
il y a 100000 Ukrainiens qui décident de
nouveau en plus de venir on s'adaptera
et on se mobilisera pour le faire on
reste on termine avec cette note de
d'espoir d'optimisme merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce débat on
va
[Musique]